uh good evening my name is stephanie i'm
new governance officer
and a new starter
and then
it is
excuse me counselor the minutes from
last meeting didn't get circulated in
time for the meeting they'll be
moved to the next meeting instead and
can you also make sure that you use a
microphone speaking just so it's picked
up on the recording please
i'm doing what i'm asking everybody else
not to do i apologize
um so we come to the presentation from
trafford college then
so
is that okay
so over to you
hi my name is laura
a student at trafford um college
studying my gcses
hello my name is ann fernandes i am a
student at traffic college old chringum
i'm currently in the equalities council
and green college assembly which is a
campaign that
manages the climate emergency in the
college and in the community
um i'm in the equalities council because
i'm passionate about student voice and
being a leader to my friends and my
classmates
[Music]
hello
my name is liberty i'm also a student at
trafford college and i'm currently
studying my a levels i'm doing geography
sociology and politics
um and
i want to just say thank you in advance
for letting me speak to the council
tonight
and
um
i'm also part of the gca and the
equalities council and i'm also
especially passionate about climate
change thank you
good evening everyone as i said i'm
laura currently studying at trafford
council
i'm also part of the equalities council
and green college assembly and part of
the female basketball team at my school
well i'll be talking about the benefit
of having a good and healthy lifestyle
they have been evidence that being
physically active helps one to be
healthier and happier in life
this involves the movement that makes
your muscles work and require calories
to burn
even if it's two times or three times a
week going for a walk or run
participating in sport activities like
swimming a volleyball could help keep
one feet if they want if they don't want
to go through the stress of lifting
weights at the gym
having a good and healthy lifestyle
increases the psychological well-being
of a person
it helps reduce symptoms of depression
stress and anxiety
it helps builds one's self-esteem and
increases the overall function of our
brain
our health mental health is very
essential is a critical component of our
health according to the world health
organization mental health is a state of
well-being in which every individual
realizes his or her potential
can cope with normal stresses of life
and work productive and fruitfully and
is able to contribute to his or her
community
but what exactly does a healthy
lifestyle entail
having a healthy lifestyle work involves
no smoking having limits on alcohol
consumption and having a good and
balanced diet
these behaviors improve both mental and
physical health
i'm going to be talking about also
talking about the benefits of exercising
to physical health
one it makes one happy
exercising regularly can increase the
production of endocrines which are known
to produce positive feelings and reduce
pain in our body
two it can reduce the risk of chronic
disease
not being physically active is a primary
cause of chronic disease like that of
type 2 diabetes heart diseases and
cancer
exercising helps build one body's
compost composition and improve insulin
sensitivity
three it improves
it helps improve skin skin health
do you know that oxidative stress occurs
when the body's antidote defense cannot
completely repair the cell damage caused
by compound known as free radicals
this can damage the structure of the
cells and negatively impact once on
one's skin
it can induce skin cells adaptations
that can help delay the appearance of
skin aging
4. it can help your brain health and
memory
exercising can improve brain function
and protect memory and thinking skills
for older people regular physical
activity helps promote change of the
brain structure and function from that
of these of conditions like alzheimer's
disease and dementia
at travel there's a leisure center where
one could go and be physically active
even if it's going there with group of
friends or family there are facilities
available to help improve our lifestyle
and make it a healthy one
i believe that reducing the cost of
membership at the trafford leisure
center especially for those under 20
that they should be a
student discount which would be more
convenient
for younger people to come in regularly
and be physically active thank you
please does anyone have any question
i'm
sorry are you okay
i didn't realize that there wasn't a
student discount for uh in the leisure
centers
so you have to pay the same as as
all other adults then
yeah we have to
ah okay thank you
anyone else
yes
um i haven't got a question but i just
wanted to
reflect really because um i thought that
was really really informative and it was
very interesting and i feel like i've
i've learned quite a lot from that so i
just wanted to say thank you very much
actually for uh for bringing that to us
thank you you're welcome anyone else
thank you
you're welcome
hello um
hello as i said before my name is ann
fernandez and today i'll be talking
about the cost of transportation in
manchester specifically in a student's
perspective
i believe that it is especially
important we address the cost of
transportation as it is a main form of
commute for most students
yes although it is just a transport
service a lot of students do rely on it
i believe that most students use the bus
or tram services and had that and had
um and have had their fair share of
issues although we can't expect a
perfect experience all the time there's
always room for improvement
a few things i would like to address is
the cost and the convenience of
transportation
personally from where i live it's been
extremely hard for me to catch the bus
as i live down in south manchester east
edisbury and they're no direct routes to
college
so to get to college and home every day
i must take the bus to town and then
come back down to college which is very
time consuming
and the bus does not come frequently and
it's never on time
so it's been easier for me to take the
tram and travel but it's awfully
expensive my parents spent around 50
pounds a month just for me to get to
college and i go to college five days a
week so it's a burden i do not want to
put on to my parents
most of the people i know have also
struggled with this problem where they
end up going to town first and then
going home or to college the lack of
certain direct bus routes increases our
travel time making harder for us to get
to college and back
most of my friends that live up in north
manchester ex spend about 20 pounds a
month a week sorry
um which is a lot of money
um especially when you go every single
day
now we could honestly just leave earlier
or
take different forms of transportation
like a taxi or a car
but it's not convenient because
not everyone is available to send their
children to school and drop them as
parents do you have work
and
taxis are also quite expensive
it's also said that some places have a
separate bus route so they end up
getting stuck in traffic especially when
there's an accident
so students end up spending more time on
transport than we should
this causes students to miss a valuable
class time that we could use to be
studying
and i do understand that with the
pandemic it is impossible to add more
bus routes but it will surely help
especially with students filling the
buses only for them to end up waiting
for the next one which will cause them
to increase their commute time
now most students could most definitely
use the rpas for the bus but not for the
trams the trams in my opinion have been
the most useful and the most convenient
form of transportation
but also quite expensive as the cost can
add up at the end of every month
i believe that the our past should also
include tram tickets by making them free
for students till they're 18 without
making the cost a barrier as getting our
education is a right not a privilege
this could bring relief to households
that could have multiple siblings that
need to pay
um for trump tickets or bus tickets or
parents to have insecure employment
this could also lead to students paying
for their ticket instead of jumping the
trams where they end up with a fine
causing them to use more inconvenient
modes of transportation
for those using the bus i believe that
we should extend our new bus routes as
well as increase the number of buses
that are going out and making them a bit
more frequent doing this could truly
help a lot of students
i believe that breaking the barrier of
transfer struggles for students could
most motivate them to get to college by
providing them all the means possible to
encourage them to get the education and
secure a broader future for themselves
thank you so much for listening do you
have any questions
yes
hello uh thank you so much for bringing
that to us and my name's adele i live in
partington and i rely heavily on the
more service and i don't know whether
you know parsington at all but we're
extremely isolated we're on the very
edge of trafford and we have literally
one boss every hour that takes us um
from partington into manchester and if
that bus breaks down if something
happens to that boss we literally stood
there for two hours you know yes um and
i completely empathize with everything
you say i think it's absolutely
brilliant
my daughter goes to college in
manchester and she uses our pass again
because we we don't have any tram we
have the boss so that is just brilliant
you know for her to be able to get
around with that but as you rightly um
state there are young people from other
parts of greater manchester who have no
support at all um and i just think it's
brilliant that you're bringing that up
but also i just really urge you to get
behind andy burnham's campaign you heard
about the uh reintegration
integrating the bus services yes
bringing back under public control yes i
have um i think i heard about it today
they've made a two pounds for adults now
exactly that is going to be massive
that's just the start you know with with
all of this sort of additional transport
and and linking it up with the tram and
everything i think it's really important
for people like you like me who rely on
the bus service for me it's transport
poverty you know we should be able to do
what other people take for granted if
your bus doesn't turn up this should be
somewhat other way of you getting to
work or college without being
continually late soaking wet exhausted
by the time you get somewhere not ready
to learn then are you cold and you know
you it just demoralizes your whole day
or when you finish you've then got to go
and stand wait around for an hour
especially in winter freezing you know
just to and then you've got homework and
if you want to eat so i just really want
to thank you for that and just to say
please keep banging the drum because
voice is like yours we need all the
support we can get people listen to
young people
and i just i really i just want to thank
you for that thank you for listening
you're very welcome
any other questions
hello another question
yeah and i think counsellor knew was
probably articulated really well what i
would have um
said actually that i really think you've
tapped into something that is very very
topical at the moment and quite rightly
so um it is such an important issue um
and i think you talked about um
how
um
how actually that you know lots of young
people don't have any alternatives but
to to catch the bus but actually we want
people lots and lots more people to be
using public transport rather than going
in cars and individual vehicles in taxes
and making that service an accessible
one an affordable one a reliable service
um that connects all of the different
parts of the area is really really
important so um like counseling you i'd
really like to thank you for bringing
that
can i just add my thanks to that i like
yourself i'm a public transport user
my attempt to be a little bit greener
but i totally understand um the tram
scenario i live
just around the corner from your college
actually just near simply station
and i work at windshield hospital which
is three miles away
but i would have to go into manchester
and get a tram out to within shore
which is very very expensive and
so i end up getting a tram into altering
them and a bus out but you know it costs
a lot of money
like yourself i spend hours standing at
bus stops but
thank you so much for raising it it's
such an important topic um we all need
to try and create a greener environment
and in order to do that we need to have
an excellent public transport system so
i it's an excellent point and please do
as um
councillor news said please keep banging
the drum i will thank you
hello um i just wanted to reiterate my
name it's liberty and um i would just
also want to say thank you again for the
opportunity to speak in front of you
tonight about something that i and many
others feel massively passionate about
climate change is something that is a
massive area of concern that we are not
concerned enough about we need to
mitigate the inevitable effects that
this is going to have on us on on a
local national and international scale
we are on the verge of being plunged
into an irreversible cycle of positive
feedback that is going to take an
astronomically long time to come back
from possibly not even in our lifetimes
i'm here to aim to create a more
sustainable future for both my college
and hopefully on a community level too
i want to carry on raising the issue of
climate change and the detrimental
impacts it will have on humanity as a
whole
in the simplest of terms we are in a
climate emergency two words that make a
whole difference
trafford currently has a plan to go
carbon neutral by 2038. this is progress
in the right direction however we do
need to be more ambitious the
government's current plan of carbon
neutrality by 2050 is not going to
prevent the earth's temperature changing
by 1.5 degrees centigrade it is not
enough to sit and listen to the facts
from the scientific perspective and
completely ignore it it is not enough to
keep on relying on gas and crude oil
mined unethically from overseas it is
not enough to sit and do nothing about
it until it's too late we have to act
now
it may seem like it is not a crisis or a
point of importance to some as it seems
for the government
however as it stands
however as it stands
the way that we change and consume
things or
or use electricity or buy clothing but
it all has an impact little by little
little means a lot here and not enough
is being done to save our future
since records began we are seeing the
highest temperatures and carbon levels
since records began it can be argued
that this is caused by natural reasons
such as volcanic eruptions orbital
changes and oceanic currents however
this is minuscule in comparison to the
problem we have caused ourselves
however to change our ways we have to
know what climate change is
climate change by definition is the
long-term shifts in weather patterns and
temperatures on earth earth has a
natural pattern of ice ages and an
interglacial period however it is
evident that we are not leaving the
interglacial period anytime soon earth
is doing the opposite it's getting
warmer
the last 20 to 30 years have been some
of the hottest on record and we are
still set to rise without human
intervention
intervention to stop it this is where we
come in currently the average person has
a yearly carbon footprint of about 10
tonnes much higher than the world
average and this has fallen very little
since 1990 however there is small scale
and large scale opportunities we can do
and take
to ensure that we stay below the world
target of 1.5 degrees centigrade you
could on a small scale use less water
use energy efficient led or halogen
light bulbs
cycle walk or take pump public trust
transport more often try to avoid fast
fashion wherever possible and shop at
places with a good transparent and
ethical sustainability strategy there
are also things that we can do to help
start a step in the right direction for
trafford as a borrower too
encouragement and promotion of the cycle
to work scheme more money in providing
works and tram lines and buses to ensure
energy efficient affordable travel
standards of social housing and private
new builds to use energy efficient
practices when building an installation
of solar energy on all new builds
greater promotion of green space is an
introduction of recreational green space
in the local community
greater recycling of local waste and an
introduction of an engine's off policy
to bus stations in order to mitigate
unnecessary air pollution by
implementing changes like this to the
way we live it paves the way for a wider
change on a national level for a greener
and more sustainable future it is only
by listening to the science and taking
accountability for our own actions as a
collective that we will achieve the
global targets and degree in a planet
together we can build a future of
community stability and sustainability
for the future of ourselves and the
future of our young people thank you do
you have any questions
go ahead
thank you liberty that was really really
interesting and it was making me feel oh
she's right
um
the uh i've started doing my own thing
i've changed the shower head on my
shower so it uses less water i have a
timer at the side of my shower that
times me no more than four minutes i've
actually started turning my shower off
after i've wet my hair so i do my hair
then i turn the shower back on again so
i'm getting into those routine i've
bought a shopping trolley instead of
going to the shops in my car
i've now got a shopping trolley that i'm
using so i'm trying my best because i
know this is so important i've not got
as much as long as you left on this
world in this uh
in this life sort of thing but i've got
grandchildren and i worry about my
grandchildren so it's really really
important but thank you for that no
problem
wow counselor maitland i'm really
impressed
really impressed the shower thing in
particular
that is very impressive um
i think i just wanted to say um
listening to your speak i think
as
as an adult um
i think it's it it really gets to you
here a little bit actually and i think
um
i think i feel really challenged by what
you've said um
it's a wake-up call isn't it and and we
can all do
um something and we all need to do more
and i think you are absolutely right you
know we need to stop just talking about
it and start doing more and so again
thank you so much and thank you to all
three of you to think you've brought um
some of the most important if not the
most important issues to us tonight so
um thank you very much for that
can i just so much for having us
thank you
thank you so much and please accept my
sincere apologies for being so late
you've raised some really important and
i can see the thought and work that's
gone into it and
i feel guilty it's my generation that
has
used up all i feel as though i'm part of
the cause of the um
the global warming i'm trying to do my
best i've got my led light bulbs i've
given up my car but you've pointed out i
think as well the thought that's gone
into
just thinking locally of the little
things that we can all do
to try and save our planet i feel that
my my generation has had the best of
everything but we've spoiled a lot of
things
um
you know and i i too have grandchildren
and i want to make
any difference i can however small
to make
the world a better place for yourselves
and future generations so thank you so
much for bringing those very important
topics to us
okay now we're going to move on to the
next agenda item um
you're more than welcome to stay with us
um i don't know if you have a time to be
back home by
do you want to stay or go
are you going to go all right well thank
you so much thank you so much for having
us my favorite meeting of the year
it's just great to see the guys here in
person
yeah all right thanks michelle
thank you
bring them back now if you want
yeah jump bring them in
put the thing
underneath otherwise
where's the best place for
them to go
yeah
do they want to come and stand
[Music]
you
awesome
can i just say how sorry i am that i was
late
just uh got caught up
um
councillor young was just saying she'd
not had a chance to do some intros so
and i can see a few new play new faces
here so
can we just go around and do a quick um
round of intro so
i'm
the late denise weston and i uh
committee obviously
i'm jane hines from the public health
team
hi i'm donna sager i'm a consultant in
public health
hi i'm kath hines and i'm the lead
member for children's services
evening everybody i'm jill mcgregor i'm
the corporate director for children's
services here in trafford
hi i'm jude brown i'm the strategic lead
for practice improvement and learning
for children's services
hi i'm stephanie freoli the new
governance officer upstairs
hello i'm amy white counselor and broad
heath ward
jane dillon counselor in david hume east
hi i'm adele new um i'm a buckle award
counsellor that's partings in carrington
and sale west
i'm sue maitland i'm councillor for
davey west debbie hume west
baby hume west
i'm the not so late david action
yet
do we need to wait for alex to come back
or
um
shall we go ahead
yeah okay
so we're going on to the
first report which is um
an update on the recruitment and
retention of social workers um
i know the reports were late and i
appreciate the reason reasons why um
but we we have had um the report so
i could ask that you you give us an
overview of the report
um and then we'll have an opportunity
for members to ask questions
so just by way of introduction jude's
going to talk us through this
report because as you've intimated
there's a lot of activity going on in
this space and i know that we've
benefited from member support in terms
of tackling some of our recruitment and
retention issues and i know it's a an
area that you're hugely interested in so
without saying any more i'll hand over
to jude if that's okay chair
thank you
um and apologies to councillor heim this
is the second time you'll have heard
this report today it was on our
improvement board this morning
and so it is quite a detailed report so
i will just try and pull out the main
points
and obviously at the start of the report
you've got information that was
presented at the last um scrutiny which
includes um some of the the
the big things that we had to do which
was
um redesign the service and that's just
to confirm that that did go live in
october
and we did roll out our care and
confidence modules of the strengthening
practice programme that is a completely
bespoke package for trafford
and that was around making sure that we
were looking after our staff
through a pandemic through an
improvement journey through redesign we
felt that was really important
and then we've done a number of things
to actually have a really systematic and
targeted approach to our recruitment and
retention
so the really pleasing things to note
that you'll see um detailed in the in
the chart that i've put in the report is
that in quarter two we did see quite a
high number of our social work staff
leaving
and there was a number of reasons for
that which i think has been before
scrutiny previously so i won't
labor too much on that point
the really pleasing thing to know is
that you can see a steady reduction
um of the number of people that are
choosing to to leave in terms of
permanent staff
and we've we definitely saw that
continue to stabilize through the west
the rest of quarter three and also what
i can say is we continue to see that um
as we come to the end of quarter four so
i think we are in a period of sustained
stabilization
and i'm not going to say that people
don't leave because people do and they
choose things they choose to leave for
very different reasons
but again it feels a little bit more
business as usual rather than that high
turnover that we were seeing
so just in terms of the categories
there's some detail there in the
information that we collate from when we
do have people that choose to leave and
i think what's really interesting is um
through the first part of this reporting
year work culture workload were the top
two reasons that people chose to leave
however
in this quarter we've seen that slightly
change and so we are seeing personal
reasons and choices
and then underneath that um little
those few bullet points
i'm actually putting the report about
where people
go on to and you'll see there that 46 of
our leavers actually say that they're
going to go to a different local
authority
and 24 state that actually they're going
to move on to agency work
most of that is around financial
elements for people
what is really interesting uh when we
looked at some of the information is
that almost 10 percent were actually
saying that they were reviewing whether
they wanted to carry on in social work
um
at all basically and i think it's really
important to know that that is not just
a trafford issue i think regionally and
nationally we are seeing that and i
don't think it's just a social work
issue either i think probably seen that
in in different parts of public service
um some feedback there as well around
why
when people leave this is what they tell
us
there were real positives in there
around people feeling that they were
supported they did have regular
one-to-ones where we didn't sort of um
report as highly was around inductions
and appraisals but it's really important
for us to note that those staff that
left were before we'd reviewed the
induction and processes
and so whilst we've reviewed the um
dedicated children's induction programme
and what we're not going to do is just
wait for the next person to leave to
tell us that it had or hadn't worked
we're actually building in some
systematic checks and balances so within
the first month of any any new starter
there was an expectation of did you have
an induction and how was it so that
we're really sort of
catching that
and there's some more information in the
report that which actually came from the
social work health check
um and and it was really pleasing to
note that you know those um sentences
there in bold i think the one of the
things that i felt quite heartened by is
that i feel safe in my role and the work
that i'm expected to do
and we know that one of our um
principles around retention is that
people don't often leave for pay and um
financial issues apart from obviously as
i've said the 24 that did
the most people leave because they don't
feel supported so that was really
positive to read
there's some more details in there
around the care and confidence program
which i won't go into detail and
hopefully i have have covered that but
what i will say is just draw your
attention to
the feedback that we've had from
strengthening practice around working
with our practitioners
and they've fed back as did the dfe
recent review there's a really strong
value base within our practitioners
and that's been consistently
demonstrated through the first half of
the programme
and i think some of the terminology
we're using is children at the center of
what we do here in trafford and it
almost runs through us like a stick of
rock so to have that external feedback
as well was really heartening
critical element now is turning all of
that passion and value into change for
children
and young people
we're now at the point where we are
preparing for the core skills part of
the programme to be delivered and whilst
there are some bottom lines within that
as in we know we need to strengthen our
assessments and plans and how we work
with families we do want to do some
collaboration
with our practitioners and what is going
to be most helpful to them through that
programme
in terms of the workforce profile what
you'll see there is the number of asyes
there are brand new newly qualified
social workers
and when i started working trafford in
in october 2020 i think we had about
nine asyes and as you'll see there we've
we've almost doubled that we have
doubled it
through the year
really pleasing to report that the
decrease has become because we've had
successful practitioners and actually
completing their asy year and you can
see also in there how we've continued to
grow because our asyes are our future
and are the experienced practitioners of
the future
you'll also see that there is a slight
reduction in the number of permanent
social workers again that's it's just to
reiterate there's the number of exits
have reduced and so that slight dip
is is
business as usual
on the flip side of that the numbers of
agency staff have slightly increased
however five of those are actually
covering secument arrangements and
maternity leave cover
in terms of the 12-month turnover figure
obviously that is much higher than we'd
want it to be however we were
significantly impacted in quarter three
quarter two um as part of as those um
quite significant exits that i've
already talked about
in terms of the data and what that looks
like it's just to remember that is a 12
month turnover so that will take us some
months to chip away at to to reduce
where we are seeing some of our turnover
is within our agency staffing and we
recognize that it is still much higher
than we would want it um however there
are a number of agency staff who have
been with us quite a significant amount
of time some of those we've we've been
able to
talk to and support in becoming
permanent members of staff i think it
was five at the last count
and two into management posts one into
an advanced practitioner and two into a
permanent social worker post so we are
literally trying every avenue to keep
these conversations going
we have reviewed um what the offer to
agency staff could be with hr colleagues
although we've got to be really mindful
that that isn't to the detriment of our
permanent staff
and there is some work um that the north
west
association for directors of children's
services are doing in terms of actually
this is a regional issue so regionally
can we do something including um a
not-for-profit agency resourcing
framework
having a cap on agency rates
and and also we there's a basic
requirement that asyes shouldn't be
going into agency work
but actually it's just to note to the
committee that in trafford we don't have
any agency staff who are asyes because
that is a contradiction of our
principles and values
and so just moving on in terms of
recruitment activity what i've put
within the within the paper is a table
and of its vacancies against the
establishment and the agency cover that
we have badged against those vacancies
and then the true picture of what the
vacancies are in terms of nobody in that
post and nobody covering it and
hopefully you can see in there that that
we've got very very few posts that
actually aren't and aren't covered which
is positive
because six months ago that looked a
very different picture
i used to rag rate it and there were
quite a lot of reds on it
and so in terms of recruitment and we've
got a continual programme of recruitment
we have our rolling advert through our
greater jobs
network platform
we've also engaged tripod as our
external recruitment and partner we've
completely refreshed the recruitment
material we've completely rebranded we
have a
a microsite which is
really
vibrant and that is now live
we've got video testimonials from
practitioners in there about what it's
actually like to work in trafford and
how we really do make the grass greener
in trafford
and
we've got our first webinar and planned
for tomorrow
um jill's already done a recording for
that and and we have a number of
practitioners joining us on that caller
and the idea is is that people can start
to get to know us before they choose
whether they want to come or not so
again
building those relationships
in terms of the management and
leadership posts i did just want to
update the committee um that we
since the last time that we updated the
committee in february we have recruited
to two more heads of service on a
permanent basis
so we only will have one um as an
interim and we're going to hold that as
an interim as that is linked to the next
part of the redesign early help so it's
really important we don't introduce more
changes
and
the head of service for vulnerable
adolescents that's a really positive
because that's been out three times for
advert and we're super excited about
that candidate coming to join us
and there's some details there around
some some of the practice managers roles
that we currently have out for advert
and again we just continue to
turn around as quickly as we can when we
get applications
shortlist
and get those interviews out there keep
people um interested and and make them
feel valued before they even walk
through the door
and so in conclusion investing in our
people um
is
underpinned by an action plan which
hopefully you've had as part of the
papers
um it continues to be our priority and
we continue to work on the many many
strands that we have
to try and and attract and retain new
and and current staff
thank you
thank you do any members have any
questions counsellor gillen
and
slightly random one here i'm just
wondering if social workers get training
on ehcps i know not all kids are jill's
looking
not all kids kids that have social
workers obviously will have an ehcb i'm
just nosing us really after that thank
you it's not nosiness and i wouldn't
have expected any less from your
counselor dylan and um you'll be pleased
to know that we've already done some
training on ehcps
in our practice fortnight that happened
in november
we're making some changes to the
electronic recording system so it's
easier for all social workers to access
and see the ehcps
jude is working with colleagues from
across the service some of our education
colleagues on quality assurance
processes for ehcp is another
topic that's close to your heart i think
in terms of the quality of those plans
but we recognize that the very point
that you're making the majority of
children with ehcps do not sit within
the children with additional needs
service so we need to make it a shared
responsibility
we've got two whole service briefing
sessions happening
tomorrow and friday and one of the
topics is all things to do with send so
that's that every practitioner across
children's services
i'm working up a really detailed um plan
of ongoing training because you're right
you know unless you experience it unless
you're used to working in that space
there are some obvious things that we do
need to strengthen
um i think you've covered i was going to
ask a question about what does the
induction actually consist of um and
would it scope across um
things like snd and ehcps but i think
you've more or less answered that jill
so one of the other things that we're
doing is when people come new to us they
need to understand the range of services
who to go to what to navigate and i
think it's not just an issue for social
work or social care professionals but
it's a partnership so one of the things
that we'll be rolling out um probably
before summer is a partnership induction
so that if you come like i did to
trafford and you don't know what
services we have who are really vibrant
third sector partners are who do i go to
if i've got question about ehcps so
really thinking much more broadly than
just in a narrow little bubble so
some exciting things that we've got in
train
thank you um cancer
thank you
thanks very much for the report
i think it is pleasing around the levers
that um you know this
this quarter it's reduced quite
significantly
and
looking at
prior to the refresh
reasons given was um for for leaving
reported that they did not feel that
they'd had uh had received coaching and
mentoring to help them develop
so i'm assuming that the
coaching and mentoring
is now actually
much improved and can you explain
can you explain what actually happened
through that process of coaching and
mentoring and how long does the
mentoring
last
it's a good question and coaching and
mentoring should be the culture in how
we practice and how we work with people
not just our staff but our families as
well
and so um it's it is improving picture
and what we've got to do is develop the
confidence in our in our managers and
our advanced practitioners in those
skills
and and i think that
having the strengthening practice and
helping deliver the care and confidence
has helped with some of that
and i also think
setting the tone from a senior
leadership point of view and and
bringing all of our new managers and
heads of service
into our leadership forum which takes
place once every two weeks
um on a monday morning and it it's how
pamela who who sort of leads on that
it's how we set some of the tone and how
we have the conversations with with
people and with our managers
and i think there's more to do
and we are again talking with
strengthening practice around we know
we've got the um the epic managers
programme
but actually how do we continue that how
do you have a reflective conversation
with a practitioner how do you coach and
you mentor them to try and challenge
their own thinking and your own and and
i think we've we've started to see the
shoots of it um but i think we've we've
definitely still got more to do
i hope that's answered that counselor
so if i can just come in counselor acton
one of the things that we did in the
redesign was re reshape our advanced
practitioner roles so previously the
advanced practitioner roles with those
practitioners that have been with us a
long time and almost as if you've earned
your stripes because you've been with us
a while whereas actually we've made a
requirement of that post to be somebody
that supports a peer within their team
that helps our newly qualified social
workers that gives the top tips about
how to write a good plan how to write a
good assessment
so a student saying it's not a time
limited offer that you will have a coach
for a fixed period of time it's the way
that we're doing things around here in
trafford
and as you know we had um ofsted in last
week and one of the things that they
really noticed was an improvement in the
quality of our supervision to our staff
which you know good quality supervision
should be reflective it should include
some of that coaching and that mentoring
so as jude says we're not there yet but
we are seeing tangible improvements in
terms of what we're doing
thank you thank you councillor maitland
thank you
thanks for that and just with regards to
the personal and professional
development of the
social workers of the managers of senior
managers
do you have a 360
sort of look at that you know getting
feedback from all angles
so what we've done is we've developed
the supervision framework um and as part
of that it's not just about the
supervision and the decision making
around children but how are we how is
our practitioner doing how is our
manager doing how are we helping them
grow and help retain them we haven't
built a 360 into that but i think it's
definitely something that we we would
like to do and build it that into the
future supervision programme
i mean as well as the things that we do
specifically in bespokely in terms of
children's social care um our
practitioners and our managers do have
their epic check-ins as well and that
gives a
a check and a balance about progress
continuous professional development
all social workers have to as part of
their social work registration say what
they've done in the last 12 months and
how that fits with the the
key skills in terms of that professional
registration
again one of the really pleasing things
that we're starting to see is more
observations of practice because one of
the best ways to understand whether
somebody's doing a good job with a child
or a family that they're working with is
to actually observe what they're saying
to come back
to the building or the virtual space and
say
that was really strong you did that
really well but jill you talk too much
and you need to listen more you know or
whatever it happens to be but but that
live observation and that live learning
so that we're continually growing and
sustaining our practitioners
i'm thinking of youth service users as
well here you know as well as peer
observation that sort of thing okay
thank you
can i just ask following on from
councillor maitland's question
do we ask for feedback from our service
users is there any upward feedback as
well
um
i've always liked to to give
and receive upward feedback in companies
i've worked for it on a more corporate
level but
um
i think to ask for upward feedback and
perhaps make it anonymous
from your staff um because people will
be frightened of saying but i'm sure
service users would be much more
outspoken um if they're dissatisfied
with the service
one of the really exciting things that
we've started to do is to introduce um
our live audits um with our service
users
small numbers at the moment but that
does involve going out having
conversations saying how was it for you
what did we do well what didn't we do
well needing to think about the timing
of when you do those live conversational
audits because if you do it at tea time
when all of the kids are around it's
probably not going to be a very
productive
period of time
being persistent because someone might
say oh no i don't fancy doing that but
actually it's really important to us and
we can learn from you so baby steps in
terms of that because you'll know from
your own experience that if you do
something through surveys or returns the
return rate is very low and it would be
much better to explore that in depth
with somebody so that's one of the
things that that we are doing
we do have surveys that go out and
particularly linked to the end of
assessments for example but the return
on that isn't particularly
good
the social work health check that that
jude reference is one of the ways where
we do get that upward feedback in terms
of what does that look like what's your
experience of management
and obviously across the whole council
we do the pulse survey we slightly
delayed that over the last year
for for obvious reasons because it felt
like taking a health check when people
were struggling in terms of the
conditions that we've all been working
in and but that will be something that
comes back on stream
okay thank you council hands did you
have a question
um i guess it's it's kind of connected
to the question and
so
and and you're part of the corporate
parenting board as well council lessons
so you'll be in those meetings when we
do get feedback from our
children and young people and and that
feedback i think is is really really
powerful
um and one of the things that they
consistently tell us
um
is that they
are impacted by the changes in social
workers so having a a number of changes
in their social workers um you know does
does cause them um some uncertainty um
and it's something that i think you know
that
makes the
um
retention and recruitment of our social
workers
absolutely critical that we keep the
social workers um that we've got so that
we can keep that level of consistency
and so we do get that feedback um and
they give us feedback on everything um
as you know
which is great and we want to work to
build um the engagement um as as far and
wide as we can do with our children and
young people so that we get in a range
of voices and that we make sure that we
listen to them
thank you um if there are no more
questions thank you for the report it's
very reassuring i'm glad to see we're
moving in the right direction um
and if we can move on to the next item
um
along the same vein really um but the
recruitment and retention of foster
carers
thank you and apologies you're going to
have to listen to me not
the head of service we've newly
recruited to our provider service in
terms of
um the group of services that include
our fostering service our residential
children's homes and it's day 11 for our
new head of service so i didn't think it
was particularly fair to ask them to
come
and talk to the the report
um
what i did want to start with is
recognizing the fantastic work that our
foster carers do
the nature of fostering has changed
immeasurably i think over years and at
times it can be
very complex very challenging but
equally it can be hugely rewarding
and we have foster carers that have been
incredibly loyal to us here in in
trafford
and
they don't just care for our children
they love our children and they do the
very best for our children so i think it
would be wrong of me to
have a report that talks about foster
care recruitment and retention without
recognizing the tremendous work that
they do
having said that one of the things that
i'm sure is the reason why um this
committee is interested in this issue is
that we have had some challenges around
recruitment activity
a little bit like the social work
recruitment it's a national issue
um and it's very much a focus of the
children's
social care review for josh mcallister
we've done some big things in terms of
the service in terms of trying to to
take that forward and one of the first
things that we did is that
um pamela and myself had a number of
meetings with a range of our foster
carers and it was really important that
we listen to them to what their
experience was the things that they were
that they felt went well and the things
that they felt didn't go so well
we also recognized that one of the
things one of the areas of service that
have been significantly impacted by
change and culture was the fostering
service
and we have completely restructured that
service into three discrete areas
a team that focuses on assessing foster
carers
a team that focuses on support for
foster carers and recognizing that we
have a number of connected carers
they're usually family members people
with a relationship to a child and care
for a named child but actually we need
to get the support to those carers right
we've spent quite a bit of time and it
might sound um silly but we've spent
quite a bit of time really questioning
who are our children in care how long
have they been in care what are their
needs what what is it that we we need to
think about
and you'll see from
the the four pie charts in the report
that
half of our children are over the age of
10.
that a significant proportion of our
children 79 have been in our care for
over two years
the great thing about that is that that
offers some stability
but it also means that we have a lot of
children that we've been looking after
for for a long time
a number of those are with members of
their own family which is why we said we
need to think about the support that we
give to family
um
we we recognize as well that we're
where we have
have not been as strong in terms of
offering our own in-house placements is
for brothers and sisters who need to
live together
there's a number of our foster carers
only have the capacity in the physical
space to care for one or two children
and if you've got a large sibling group
of five we are needing to go to the
independent sector for that
inevitably the pandemic has impacted on
recruitment activity um but even before
that our recruitment activity was not as
strong as we wanted to do as we wanted
it to be
and one of the reasons that we have
strengthened the staffing levels in the
fostering service is so that we can be
more responsive
some of the things that our carers would
tell us are um well i might when my
supervising social worker isn't there
i'm getting somebody on duty i don't
have a relationship with that person i
want to have a consistent person
we know that we're very good at getting
initial enquiries but what we're not so
good at is converting those into real
assessments people that want to pursue a
career and their work in terms of
fostering
the report
contains the detail of what that looks
like and as you will see one of our
biggest issues has been that we've
actually lost more carers than we've
recruited in the year
some of that is um life choices so
people who are coming to the end of
their fostering career who have made
decisions that they they want to retire
some of that has been through adverse
circumstances such as a bereavement or a
health issue which fundamentally
can lead people to change and think
about what what's right for them what's
right for their families
some of that has been because we've
needed to address some issues about
whether the quality of care was good
enough and would this be good enough for
our own children
what we have started to do is engage
both at a gm level and um to progress
some things locally here in in trafford
that we think are really innovative that
will help us um
to attract more people we've engaged in
digital responses
seen a lot of hits in terms of adverts
and using digital media as an initial
interest but that's not translating into
ongoing assessments so we have um agreed
that we will go back to some of those
people in a year's time we're seeing a
lot of women for example on mobile
phones oh that looks interesting i'll
have a little look at that
um but then that not coming to something
so we need to better understand that
we have worked to speed up our
recruitment processes
and whilst we've only recruited four new
mainstream carers we've continued to
recruit a lot of connected carers
friends and family carers and we've also
converted some of those carers to be
special guardians so this year we will
have had 21 people go on to become
special guardians
so that means instead of having
the level of intrusion from having to do
you named fostering training um have a
social worker come
come every um six weeks to see you that
people are giving the responsibility for
caring for their nieces nephews
grandchildren and but that's underpinned
by a legal order
we've done quite a bit of benchmarking
with other local authorities and um i
think you'll see on page 10 of the
report that all figures in terms of
approvals look
quite low in comparison to some of those
and local authorities that have
responded
i think we need to go back and just
check whether that includes friends and
family carers as well because we've
excluded our friends and family carers
so i think there might be a little bit
of a distortion there
a little bit like the workforce report
that we've talked about we have a
dedicated project fostering so we have a
dedicated plan that includes how are we
going to recruit more carers how are we
going to better support our carers what
are we going to do to retain and sustain
them
and that's been quite a deliberate
approach so starting from that listening
to our foster carers so that we can use
their knowledge skills and expertise to
think about how we attract new in
and equally just like the the social
work report listening to what our carers
want in terms of ongoing support
we have to get that right and we
we've
worked hard at that but we've still got
more to do so the report references some
of the bespoke support groups um
the mail carers group and on some of the
things that carers have said if we had
um
if we continue with our peer mentoring
for example that is something that we
find really really helpful
um
i guess at that point because you have
got a detailed report one of the more
interesting things would be to open it
up for questions because i know it's an
area that you all feel passionately
about and i'm sure you will want to
probe and challenge
do any members have questions can i take
councillor maitland and then council
dylan
i appreciate what you're doing um
in a greater manchester way of thinking
and working but have we gone
more national have we looked even
further and part out to see
are there some absolutely fantastic
experts out there
so one of the projects that is mentioned
in the report is the work that we're
doing with trafford housing trust so
we've got a national organization corum
working with us and it's based on some
work that was
initiated in islington
so actually looking at if we look at
bespoke housing solutions for existing
carers whether they can actually
care for more children rather than just
the one or the two children
really understanding what those housing
needs are
but equally thinking about some of our
ambitious projects in terms of new build
and how we can maybe incentivize in
terms of some of that social housing and
people being um a carer for us
so in short yes we are looking at what
um is best practice
we are being quite daring greater
manchester are really interested in
seeing how our
project with trafford housing trust goes
because it's something that's been
talked about but we've put our toe in
the water to to try and develop that
some of the things that we do to support
carers like our pace training um
is is benchmarked on national best
practice so always looking um but it is
a national issue in terms of um
recruitment of foster carers
counselor dylan
can i be really cheeky and ask questions
about fostering but not exactly about
the subject is that okay
i'm just really interested in how you
choose where if you get a child that is
in need of
going to somebody's home
how do you choose where that child goes
is it about who's got the space that's
that's all i wanted to ask then
no it's not about who's got the space so
we need to think about the needs of that
child we need to think about the skills
of that foster carer um we need to think
about what their their reviews say about
how
how um placements that they might have
had previously go
have gone so we have a rigorous matching
process
and sometimes we do have to make
difficult decisions though because you
know if somebody hasn't got somewhere to
sleep at night sometimes we have to
think what can we do to support this to
make it the the best it possibly can be
but it does have to be needs-led rather
than there's a bed over there
council act
yeah i mean i think this
is a really important subject for the
council um
we we we
probably all know that
if you can foster i think it is the best
best probably that um
you you can
have in terms of the provision
if it's done right obviously
um
and
it is actually
less expensive as well
so there's these two things in there to
the equation
and it's it's how we actually
um
address
those two issues
really um because one goes with the
other
um because if
if you're paying out a lot of money
to have a another provision rather than
um
a foster carer
then
you know those
children are losing out in a way
um
so
i know that you're trying everything
that you possibly can and recognize that
because i'm i'm on the parenting board
and
i'm hoping that we will get there
but it is disappointing that you know
we're one of the lowest in in
sort of recruiting um
and
and it's
um
you know
it's really important that we
find out
exactly why that is and
you know put it right basically
but you know i don't want to be
critical but i think it is
i think it is such an important
matter
and i think everybody kind of recognizes
i think there's a couple of things um
you're absolutely right our recruitment
rate is not where we want it to be so at
the start of of the year we set a target
of 15 and we haven't recruited 15 new
mainstream carers we have recruited for
we've got four more in in train so
as we go into the new financial year
we'll start from a position of
achieving what we've done in the whole
year
in that very short period that in itself
tells tells the story doesn't it that
the activity and the energy wasn't where
where it needs to be
i think it's really important that we
recognize like i say over 50 of our
children in our care live with a family
member either with their own parents or
um with a connected carer so
understanding that
has been really important to us to to
think about why is that
the biggest marketing um strategy that
any work can have is word of mouth it's
the same for our social workers it's the
same for our foster carers if we make
trafford the local authority of choice
for our foster carers if we get the
support offer right to them if we listen
to what works for them and
value their skills and expertise then
word of mouth is a very very powerful
tool isn't it so that's why some of the
things that we've needed to do
in this year have been to
almost re-engage with some of our carers
to hear the things that have gone really
well to celebrate those successes but
equally to hear some of the things that
hasn't been such a positive experience
for them um because you're right it
it's not just cost effective you know
people should have a right to living in
a family shouldn't they
our approach to permanence and the work
that we're doing that has started from
the best place for children to live and
grow is in their families
wherever it's safe to do so if it's not
safe to do so then we want to make sure
that they have loving family homes
and we need to make sure that um we get
the support to our foster carers right
to enable that
so i don't think it's a criticism
counselor acton i think it's it's a very
um
appropriate challenge the figures are
not where we need to be and we need to
improve can i just come back just just
very silently really
while i was mentioning mentioning the
resources that
if we put
i know
it's a chicken in the egg really but if
we put the
resource from
the areas where we don't
have a
better
result for the for the child
into the foster carers to to to give
that support
i know it's not all about money um but
he
he
it is about staff time and things like
that so to to be able to give that kind
of
support
to the
um
you know to the foster carers because
that's what they
say that they need don't they really as
much support as they possibly can i'm
not saying they don't get the support
i'm saying that you know if we want to
be the best and we've got to give them
the best support
and some of the things that they say are
really helpful in terms of support is
things like
our looked after children's
cams team
and one of the things at the moment is
the lead psychologist
has
left she's emigrated with a husband to
somewhere i think like the cayman
islands
um somewhere really exotic um so we're
in the process of recruiting um to that
post that's a health-led post so health
colleagues are recruiting to it and we
know that all foster carers really value
that support and some of that isn't
necessarily about direct interventions
with children it's about the strategies
you know if you've got somebody that's
really distressed and um breaking things
or
trying to climb out of windows and we do
have some children with that level of
distress
how you cope and manage with that
you've not just got to be confident you
will have questions
you know
looking after children who go missing is
hugely anxiety provoking
so
you're absolutely right the support and
the care
that we give to the people that are
caring for our children is really really
important and it is an investor to save
you're absolutely right
thank you
can i take counsellor new first and then
councillor maitland again yeah uh it's
more of an observation really kind of
based upon what you just said there um i
worked with um looked after children in
trafford's children's homes for just
over 10 years
and i worked mainly with their teenagers
and
the the amount of emotional resilience
a sense of humor um
just the complete madness sometimes that
you were seeing on a shift you know you
couldn't describe it to somebody um and
we had some people who would come into
the into the role you know we had an
ex-fireman we had an ex-boys brigade
uh leader and these were people who felt
they were really equipped you know they
see some really
rough things they dealt with some really
emotional situations you're faced with
a 13 year old child who's so emotionally
distressed is trying to remove his face
with a razor blade nothing can prepare
you for that um but then
i i think
that there's quite a lot of um a lot of
some of the advertisements that i see
it's um
it's not quite realistic enough it's not
quite you know
you you know this is gonna take all of
your resource because as you said you
know um a young person who's continually
going missing and when you know what's
happening to that young person when
they're continually going missing and
there is nothing you can do to prevent
that situation because of the you know
the law and things like that it takes so
much doesn't it and i think with the
best will in the world if if you've also
got your your own children and your your
partner and you know
this is having this effect on you i just
think you know sometimes i think you
know
kind of give people the worst possible
case scenario and then everything else
is a bit more of a blessing that's how i
went into residential work with you know
like sometimes i know it sounds off
you'd be thinking well nobody died last
night and sometimes that's how bad it is
you know and i guess there's two things
in that counseling you um the first
thing that i would say i think the best
of us started in residential care i
include myself in that
and
and whilst i'm being flippant there i
think it is a very serious point that
actually
unless you've um
shared some of those experiences it is
very difficult to anticipate and imagine
what that looks like the nature of
fostering has changed immeasurably so
some of the people that were interested
in being carers for us we've had to say
not now because they were only people
that could take very young babies we
don't have that need
our greatest gap is for siblings
brothers and sisters who can live
together and teenagers and sometimes
just the relentless nature of some of
the trauma that our teenagers have
experienced does mean that you need more
than one person so for some of our
children
living in group living in residential is
the right option and
and i think it's a really well made
point our carers whether they happen to
be residential staff or foster carers
the amount of personal resilience that
you need
so we need to make sure not just that
the support is is really high quality
with the training
and that's some of the things that you
talked about in terms of coaching and
mentoring and just come on let's have a
cuppa
um you know we have um
progressed our peer mentoring scheme and
just having somebody that can empathize
and say i know what you're going through
is really really important so thank you
for sharing that i didn't know that's
where you'd
spend some of your time in your career
earlier but like i say i think
residential care is a good place to
start
thank you councillor maitland did you
have another question
could you just um i can't
i couldn't print out in color and it was
the figures really it's difficult to see
um
how many children have we got um
with
internal foster carers at the moment and
how many are with external at the moment
so
overall we've got 372 children in our
care at the moment and in terms of our
internal foster carers we've got 101
children it's in one of the tables as
well further on in the report councillor
maitland
we've got
113 um
children that are living with their
connected carers
and we've got 75 children that are
living with their own parents and that's
what i mean half of half of our children
are living
with with their own families or
relatives
and so there's something about
balance and practice as well for us to
think about
so
um
out of those children that are in in our
care but not with relatives the majority
are with our foster carers
how many with external that i can't make
out which one
it says on the chart 31 but i think it's
gone up by one um it's 32 at the moment
it's difficult to know our network
because it's not
much easier
nicki bishop would shout at me for
printing out in colour
i know but we can't tell what's what
so those 31 children though um
they're in independent fostering
agencies yes yeah and that's that's
really costly isn't it i suppose what
i'm saying is it's not as costly as
external residential they are our most
expensive so the average cost of an
external residential um placement it's
about four thousand pounds a week and my
most expensive one at the moment is
seven thousand pounds a week my goodness
just to just say
sorry i didn't say that just to say
some of those external residential
placements
are needed though as well um
there are we do have some um
young people who
do need that level of support and we do
need them to be so it is really really
expensive and it wouldn't you know it
would never be um something that we
would
opt for or or choose but there are
sometimes occasions where that's needed
but in terms of the um independent
foster
agency that that again wouldn't be our
choice but
and that's why it's so important as yeah
yeah definitely so so important that we
recruit our own definitely and just to
come back in on the um
external fostering placements the
majority of those offer brothers and
sisters that need to live together so
our gap in terms of where we want to
target for our recruitment is for older
young people that
can successfully live in families
and for brothers and sisters to be able
to live together which is why the
innovative work around housing solutions
so she can take more than one child as a
foster carer
it really links into what our gap is
thank you if there are no more questions
thank you so much for the report i'm
particularly um
pleased to see that
there's um more being put into place to
support
our foster carers who would do a
fantastic job it must have been so
difficult particularly through the
pandemic and over the last couple of
years for them so um
thank you and
um
[Music]
i think that's all i've got to say
sorry
can we move on to the next item which is
healthy weight amongst children um we
have had the reports in advance but if
you could give us an overview if you
wouldn't mind of
the highlights and what works being done
to improve the situation thank you yep
no problem
it's fine there's not much on the slides
i'll just read them because they're
behind you anyway um so
yeah brief overview of the report and
healthy weight in children young people
there's a strong social gradient in
excess weight so children living in our
most deprived communities have much
higher rates
of excess weight and unfortunately in
the last two years those inequalities
have widened due to the impact of covert
that's not just in trafford that's
nationally it's been seen
from our national child measurement
program measurements across the country
across the northwest so not just us
unfortunately
and the downside is that there's
currently not really a very strong
evidence base in terms of what works um
to support children and young people to
lose weight once they're at the point
where they um
they are overweight
um
and so
one of the things that has been
happening nationally has been that the
office for health improvement and
disparities formerly public health
england have worked we're working with
11 local authority areas to pilot some
um
different ways of working with children
young people and their families to
support them to lose weight and
but we don't know any of the results of
those yet but the aim is to start to
build that evidence base because with
adult weight management there's loads
and loads of evidence in terms of what
works what doesn't work what settings
and kind of what skills people need we
just don't have that for children young
people at the moment which makes it a
little bit harder
so in terms of the work we currently do
in trafford and we deliver the national
child measurement program um ncmp for
short
with
children in reception and year six
last year it was reduced to a 10 sample
because of all the pressures within
schools and within the school health
team
and there's also a two and a half year
check where height and weight of
children is
is measured and recorded
but i think that the uptake of that
understand itself reported so if parents
don't want to submit that information
then we don't have um such great data
and
we have support for children young
people and families and from school
nurses and health visitors so they will
proactively pick up where they do have
those measurements they will do
interventions with those families to
support them around healthy eating and
being more active
and during the ncmp program as well the
school nurses will deliver a healthy
lifestyle talk to every year six class
when they go in to do those measurements
um
and following the measurements there's
then proactive contact and
with the families of the children who
are um in the very overweight category
so before they get a feedback letter um
the school nurses will generally ring
those families and talk through the
results and explain to them what that
means and what support is available
and
we also have a children young people's
specialist weight management service
which is provided by mft and and that's
for children who are above the 98 centil
so in the very overweight category and
and also if children are in the
overweight category but if there are any
safeguarding concerns they'll also um be
seen through that service
and
again during covid that service was
stood down and so there have been
significant waiting lists which are now
i think just about getting to the stage
that they were pre-covered
and the school nurse and health visitor
support is now back up and running so
again school nurses were
absolutely
to capacity dealing with um vaccination
program and other things that were
putting on to them
so in terms of because we don't have a
national evidence base that tells us
what works and what we should commission
and
one of the pieces of work that i've been
working with colleagues is to try and
build our local evidence base and
actually pilot some programs and look at
what might work for our trafford
families so we want to know what and
some of them kind of more formal trials
and pilots are doing across the country
but and we're also trying to look at
what works locally as well
so um
we've been working with foundation 92
who are the community foundation from
salford city football club
and
and they've developed a family healthy
lifestyle program which they've been
focusing on and
the areas that experience the greatest
health inequalities so they've worked
with families in sale west partington
and stretford they've had um
most of their referrals through the
early help team so far which has been
really positive
um and it's looking at a whole family
approach and
talking to families around healthy
eating food getting more active but also
a big focus on mental well-being as well
i
it's perfect timing that i'm getting the
first kind of set of real outcomes and
results from those next week
so i can't unfortunately share those
with you but um kind of anecdotally the
family feedback has been that's been
really helpful and really positive
program but we need to kind of see what
those outcomes are in terms of people's
um behaviors and whether that has an
impact um
on the weight and the health of children
within those families
and
we're also working with the healthy
learning trust at flixton girls school
and they've developed a program um
similar healthy lifestyle program but
based in schools
and
for primary schools and um
again we're working with our sports club
foundations because they already work
within primary schools they've got the
links there and
they're used to working with those
children and they're going to be trained
to deliver the core strength program
which again focuses on food on physical
activity and mental well-being and and
there's also a lot of stuff in there
around kind of confidence self-esteem
and
so self-efficacy around children's
health
and we're going to the the training for
that is taking place in april
um and it's going to be piloted with
the 10 primary schools in trafford which
we know have got higher than average
excess weight in reception and year six
so focusing on the schools where we know
that we've already got higher rates of
excess weight
and and delivery of that will be
starting after easter so this is us
basically trying to build our evidence
base and look at what works um locally
so
assuming all those programs
get get the results and the outcomes
that we want them to achieve we then
have support from school nurses and
health visitors working on a one-to-one
level
we've got the specialist weight
management team again working with
individual families and then we'd have
some community focus and some school
focus
more holistic healthy lifestyle programs
as well so trying to look at a range of
things a range of interventions which
would hopefully
most families would find
something within that range that would
work for their family
and we're also and one of the national
pilot sites is in thameside and also
made contact with them to find out kind
of what their initial programs look like
and what the results have been it's
obviously a very different demographic
from trafford but they're the the most
local site so looking to learn from them
as well
so in terms of our next steps um
the healthy weight strategy the draft
has been signed off by the health and
wellbeing board so the next step is um
public consultation on the strategy and
then to co-produce an action plan um
later on this year
um
and we want to involve
our residents in producing that action
plan it's no good um people sitting in a
meeting room and deciding what we think
we actually want to work with our
residents say well what would help you
what are the barriers um we know that
there are going to be issues around um
access and affordability of healthy food
and also the the combination of that
with um
rising fuel prices that it it's all very
well you may be able to afford to buy
the food if you then can't afford to put
your oven on to cook the food so we've
got that it's a it's a going to be a
really huge piece of work that we need
to look at what we can do
um to address a really complex issue
really
um
there's some work um the food standards
agency looking to pilot with
environmental health teams in terms of
school food standards so i'm not sure if
people are aware there's school food
standards that all um
maintain schools should adhere to
anecdotally
i think it's variable um in terms of how
well those are adhered to but also the
standards themselves aren't particularly
stringent um
so
this piece of work the food standards
agency looking to do is for when
environmental health officers do their
food safety checks that they can also
review um
the school food standards within each
school as well
so um we're hoping to
be one of the pilot sites that will
deliver that piece of work
um
and as i said we need to evaluate the
outcomes from the pilot programmes that
we're working on now
and use that to inform our commissioning
moving forwards
and i think
that is everything so hopefully that's a
bit of a shorter summary of the report
oh that's great thank you does anybody
have any questions
so i'll take counselor acton and then
cancel the new case
yeah it was just on the
um
where it says on page two that is
currently no guidance on different
bmi ranges for black and minority ethnic
children
um
so
does that cause you a lot of problems
or you know why are those differences
and so for adults there are um
different bmi cutoff points and this is
goes back to there's been loads of
research in adults and less in children
so um
for adults particularly from a south
asian background at a lower bmi they're
more likely to experience some of the
um
health conditions related to excess
weight things like diabetes a lower bmi
than people from a white background
we don't there just isn't the evidence
for children there have been
some
kind of standalone studies which have
said um
that it's likely that bmi
um overestimates
um excess weight in children from a
black background
but it's not there's only been kind of
one or two studies that say that so it's
kind of emerging evidence um
that makes it really difficult because
in enough to answer your question in
terms of does it cause as many problems
it can do when a parent receives an ncmp
letter google's
whatever it might be comes up with one
or two studies and says well this says
and they're quite right that it may have
an impact
at the moment the guidance is we
in the absence of any better evidence
we have the bmi categories and cut offs
that we have but we do have to
understand that they may not be
appropriate for everyone but
for the vast majority they will be so
it's it's a really difficult one
thank you commerce councillor young and
then council and you had a question as
well
i just wonder
because i've been looking at the
children in the school of which i'm a
governor but i'm in the part of trafford
where possibly
the children are not so
[Music]
likely to be overweight because it's
it's the better off
part of the
borrower and
frankly looking at the children in some
vincent school where i'm a governor you
don't really see many children who are
overweight i was wondering do you
actually have
any figures as to
exactly where in traffic the problems
are and what is the proportion of
children in trafford who who are having
problems and actually again
has it been narrowed down to
which are the children who were
overweight purely because they don't
exercise enough as opposed to the ones
who maybe have diabetes or whatever it
is
you know overweight because of the liver
yes so through the national child
measurement program we have data at
school level and an individual level um
at an individual level it's used by the
um school nursing team to work with
individual families at a school level
each school will get a feedback letter
every year after the measurement program
which will tell them
what proportion of their children in
reception are underweight healthy weight
overweight or very overweight and and i
think that's also broken down into um
boys and girls as well
so yes we have that um
it's not publicly available at a school
level it generally the schools receive
that data um
but it's not published at that at that
level what we do have is um what is
publicly available is the data by lower
super output area so we can
um
we can see
different areas and kind of what the
proportions within those um
within those areas are but you're right
as i said it's there is a very clear
social gradient and you will find that
in i mean there was one school
going back in 2019 one school in
ermeston i think where in year six every
child was a healthy weight
um it was the only school um but you
will tend to see that let's say in
schools in more affluent areas will have
lower lower percentage um overweight and
schools in the more deprived areas will
have higher percentage
but we do know in traffic precisely
where we've got to concentrate almost
yeah yeah we do yeah
thank you councillor new did you have a
question hi yeah yeah um it's probably
really straightforward and simple but
part of the one-to-one work that's
undertaken with families
uh is budgeting and menu planning uh
cooking are those kind of things covered
um there was a family that i knew quite
recently um they were doing a food
skills course
and the moms said oh you know it's all
very well saying that but i don't cook
you know it was so simple it was
everything was bought in or you know it
was all takeaway and it was
you know just it was such a breath of
fresh air for her for somebody to
actually sit down and show her how to
make a healthy meal and then she found
at the end of the week
she had money left and it was a
revelation for her because she'd never
been parented in that way she was just
doing the best things she could for her
family and it really wasn't i opened a
forum so things like that makes such a
difference don't they yeah and and
that's one of the things the family
program that foundation 92 have been
delivering that's one of the things that
they've been working with um
particularly looking at cooking on a
budget cooking skills and they've been
linking in with the bread and butter
thing and the good food bag and sale to
support families to be able to actually
get hold of um
food at a price that they can afford and
support them with the skills to them
know what to do with it because
um
you see in the media people will come
out and say well healthy foods perfectly
cheap you can buy four carrots and three
potatoes and you can make a soup and
it's all fine but when some of the
issues that families talk to us about is
that that's fine but what if the
children don't like it they're not used
to eating that food then they've wasted
their food budget and they still need to
eat so
it's such a complex system
that and like say when people
haven't
got necessarily the skills the time
you know the risk to be able to
make something different it's it's yeah
it's a it's a hugely complex uh
situation and it's hard to try and cover
all of those avenues it is and i think
you know judgment as well sometimes
plays a big part in things yeah people
are actually mortified when they find
out that you know people think that
their child is obese and you know it's
down to them you know the the denial i i
see you know but at the end of the day
as you say if you've got the right
people delivering that training and the
judgment is taken away that's half the
battle yeah and addressing stigma is one
of the kind of key actions within the
healthy weight strategy and both with
children and adults and
there's been a lot of conversations kind
of across the northwest within with
colleagues in other authorities about
how to avoid stigmatizing language and
actions and
you know
there's essentially
our environment that we live in makes it
harder to be a healthy weight yeah um so
you know we shouldn't be stigmatizing
people it's not necessarily that they've
made poor choices it's bad parenting
it's really hard yeah and it's not too
late as well that's the good thing isn't
it
yeah i think um councilor news actually
made the point that i was going to make
myself that
a lot of
i was brought up on a homemade dinner
every night my children when they were
younger um
none of them were obese because they
were active and it they had a
home-cooked dinner every night but i
think as they get older
you're working longer hours there's a
lot more processed food available
you know and i think
it's just educating
the generation of mums as well that have
probably been brought up on processed
food
to learn how to
cook stuff from basically i remember a
little girl coming to our house would
see
some years ago now and
i was spending potatoes
and she didn't know what they were
because of chips came in a bag
you know it was she'd never seen a raw
potato
um you know and i think it's i think
this is sadly where the closure of the
children's centers has had an impact as
well
because that that looked after the
parent as well as the child
um
but i think it's it's a marvelous thing
if we can liaise and actually get people
cooking from scratch and you can feed a
family
with fresh
um ingredients yeah it's changing the
food culture isn't it so we've kind of
gone down one route and it's trying to
bring it back to where we were you know
a few decades ago where like say people
did cook from scratch because
essentially people have more time um
yeah
isn't just cooking from scratch because
i mean i've got six grandchildren and if
you're cooking for them you're thinking
what shall i make you'll do this so
we'll so and so won't eat this and so
and so won't eat that and trying to cook
a meal that
you really end up with cooking something
that you know the children are going to
eat and if you're taking fortunately my
grandchildren are
not not overweight at the moment but
they're still young enough to be
controllable but when they get a bit
older i know what it'll be like when
they're saying i don't want this and i
won't that and i'm going to go and buy
this
it's not easy for parents at all now
this is the worry i have
i think as well as they get i don't know
what school lunches are like these days
but it's
it was meat potatoes and veg but when i
was had school dinners i didn't always
eat it but um
you know i think it is more fast food
type of thing and particularly when they
get beyond and they go on to secondary
school where
they can basically choose to have
three pastry items or that there's no
control over that and that's very
difficult to deal with isn't it it is
yeah i mean the school food standards
were meant to address that um
diplomatically i'm not sure they always
do um
[Music]
at primary school
i think there's it's less of a problem
but you're right i think part of the
thing is that schools want the kids to
eat the school food so they want to make
it something that they're going to like
and if you've got children who've been
brought up
eating certain foods they're more likely
to eat those so
it's it starts kind of before school we
know that kind of
first food weaning
early experience of food is is really
important because otherwise by the time
they get to school you're fighting a
losing battle um
my personal bugbear is that the school
food standards allow gives that gives a
pudding for every meal which
i don't know about anyone else i don't
have a pudding with my lunch every day
um
sorry am i okay i i never had dessert
uh i think we had one yoga each a week
we could choose a yoga teach and that
was it was how it was then in those days
in where i lived
um but my husband had a dessert
every after every every meal and he has
to have something sweet now and he has
he's not colossal but he has a weight
problem you know so
and he stayed with him all the way you
know but we're definitely sure start
children's centers that was the biggest
loss you know we still have the odd one
but the biggest loss ever
and chapman monroe
yep
she's a bit of a hero isn't she she can
help people i think and you can get her
sort of information stretched across and
shared everywhere it'd be great wouldn't
then i think about using some of the
kind of
celebrities front of a better word do
the work that marcus rashford and tom
carriage do with their full-time meals
you know i think that's part of that for
me needs to form part of these services
because actually they're people that
people can relate to and can engage with
so yeah
sorry how's she saying about the sulphur
community
when they're they're involved it really
helps doesn't it yeah the big football
clubs and rugby clubs it does
alex did you want to come in there and i
know um council hines has got a question
i'm sorry
yeah i was just going to ask quickly and
talk about work at school so if you've
done any work around uh with schools
around the design of their lunch
cafeterias and stuff so they're doing
stuff like putting the healthy options
first so children are more likely to
pick them up and you know chopping up
pieces of paper and stuff like that
the work with schools is top of the list
now now that we're kind of just about
back to normal i mean touching wood and
yeah i'm really keen to work with
schools and
it's a lot
probably the easiest way to kind of get
that engagement is through our um
trafford services
meal service where we can start to work
with them and work with them
the cooks and the chefs that work in the
schools but yes
it's school food is
one of the top priorities
[Music]
council hines did you want to add
something yeah only briefly it was only
to say that i think um
where we can influence
and i know there are some really um
strict guidelines about what you can and
can't influence through the planning
process but through our local plan where
we can as a local authority
influence um
the types of availability of um
food outlets i think that is so critical
um in terms of because you talked before
council young about different parts of
the borough and we know in some parts of
the borough um having that access to
affordable um healthy food is quite
limited actually and if you haven't got
a counsellor new talks before about
not having um access to decent public
transport and if you can't travel um to
go and buy food and it isn't local it's
not within walking distance and you know
some of these
local um supermarkets have
they sell food at a premium price it's
not they they're bigger outlet prices
and things like that and that has a
massive impact so that people are more
reliant on processed food
and likewise with um
your takeaway outlets being near schools
and all those sorts of things and i know
the planning laws are quite um
prohibitive in some ways but where we
can influence it as a local authority i
think we we should be thank you
thank you and thank you so much for
bringing us the report this year very
interesting and you know keep up the
good work
thank you
the report on school funding um
cognizant of the time we had decided to
defer until the next meeting and i'm not
aware of any urgent business
so i'd like to thank
um everybody for coming with your
presentations tonight special thanks to
the scrutiny committee members
um
councillor london had to send his
apologies but it asked me to pass on his
best wishes
and i'd like to say a special thanks to
councillor dylan who is stepping down in
may and i'm going to miss her so much
she loves it so much but thank you
thank you so much uh your your
contributions have been absolutely the
lift experience is is
the greatest way of learning and
presenting problems to us and
you've been absolutely excellent jen and
i will miss you
and can i also thank alex um
for his i know he's been thrown at the
deep end and i know he's managing
all the committees at the moment but
thank you so much and i'd like to
welcome stephanie on board and uh
had a bit of a taster of what you're
going to have to put with
and with that i'll close the meeting i
think we'll
miss the football going home thankfully
and uh
wish you all a safe journey home
[Music]
you